this week on brian ross investigates
the young woman who survived minneapolis
police officer derrick shorten
shall now testify against him in the
george floyd trial
he treated her in a similar manner that
he treated
mr floyd one of the scores of cases of
alleged police brutality in minneapolis
caught on police body cam tape like what
happened to this woman
who was arrested for jaywalking these
stupid games get stupid prizes
that's what happens they're recording
themselves they know that somebody will
eventually get a hold of video and
review it
and they still abuse the citizen that
they're involved with plus
after a hard-fought campaign they're
counting the votes in alabama
for and against a union at a big amazon
fulfillment center
in the bathroom stalls they have
anti-union messages
posted at eye level if you're sitting on
the toilet
the outcome could force the giant
company to change the way it does
business
and the way it treats its employees no
one wants to come to work and be treated
like a machine
gun treated like they're nothing
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices of the
editors of meteorites
educate me tell me when you have heard
him
say racist things from the lawn crime
trial network
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with the murder
trial of derek chopin
the judge says the trial is going to
last about four weeks and we now know
that in that four weeks the jury is
going to hear a lot about the background
and the record
of the former police officer rhonda
that's right brian
and while chauvin has been on the force
for 18 years and there were a lot of
complaints about him
the trial judges ruled prosecutors can
only bring up
two past evidence involving chovin one
where he roughed up a woman pinning her
to the ground put his knee in her back
and the other when after restraining a
suspect
chobin was credited with giving
life-saving measures
so in both cases though rhonda it
appears that'll be damaging to
derek shovin's defense
that's right in the first incident it
shows he roughed up a suspect in a
similar manner in the second incident it
shows he knew
what the life-saving techniques were
that he had
he had learned how to save a suspect
after restraining them
so the jury certainly is going to hear
some dramatic testimony from two
individuals with direct contact with
derrick sheldon
this is zoya code one of two witnesses
the prosecution wants to call
to testify about how they were treated
in previous incidents
her lawyer zoroslof lederman says it
grew out of a domestic dispute
what can the zoya code testify to
well mrs code had a similar encounter
with mr chavin where
he was taking her into custody and he
treated her in a similar manner that he
treated
um mr floyd uh the the issue there is
this um
kneeing over the neck um this is what
the
this is what the prosecution was looking
for in terms of getting her
testimony in and i also believe that
this is what the judge looked at as well
in determining that her
testimony will be allowed um is the
the specific um the specific use of
force and how it was carried out
and the similarities between her
incident
and mr floyd in terms of how officer
chavin used force
and how seriously if at all was she
injured in the encounter
anytime you have a police officer who
is on top of you you're being restrained
they're applying pressure to your neck
anybody who's being arrested is already
under stress
it's not a very pleasant situation to be
in
i prefer not to go into detail just
because she's expected to testify at
trial and i don't want to create
any other issues well similar that we
saw with the settlement i don't want to
have
a problem come up in the trial where i
tell you something that may end up
causing more
questions of the jury so i prefer to
leave that as is
but if she does testify she will tell
her story and you'll be able to see what
happened
and you expect it to be impactful i
i think about yes and what is she like
she's a you know a regular person just
like many other people that are
often abused by the police um similar to
numerous other cases i've handled where
um the police show up to a situation
that
really doesn't doesn't require the use
of force
and things spin out of control and
people end up being injured
this is a video that lederman says shows
another of his clients being
violently arrested after what he says
was simply a jaywalking violation
play stupid games and get stupid prizes
that's what happened
the case led to an out-of-court
settlement with minneapolis for almost
60 thousand dollars
later but says the fact that the police
would conduct themselves that way
knowing it was all being recorded on a
body camera is
very telling they're recording
themselves they know that somebody will
eventually get a hold of video and
review it
and they still abuse the citizen that
they're involved with in yet another
case
also recorded on police body cameras one
of his clients was pulled from her car
at gunpoint
after a traffic stop i said this police
officer just pulled me over for using my
gps
which is not against the law let me ask
you something could you turn your car
off please
why do i need to turn my car turn it off
step out of the vehicle right now
put your hands up
and what did that case tell you about
the culture
what the case tells me is that uh police
officers have
an irrational fear of of of minority
citizens
in the city of minneapolis um that we're
still living in in the days of 50 years
ago
and again this is this is something that
needs to change internally um
settlements uh and criminal charges in
my view are not effective
um the police department itself has to
do more
to make sure that the the officers
treat every single person with respect
and just last week
another incident that raised issues when
two teenage boys were taken into custody
after an alleged carjacking with one of
them hit by an officer
this is police brutality bro stop stop
stop that guy step back
hey stop why did you hit him
y'all cannot do that shit bro the police
chief has now asked for the community to
give him more time to investigate
allow us the time to conduct a thorough
investigation as mayor frye indicated
this is
this real recent we are going to conduct
a very thorough investigation
but community activists were outraged
we want justice
for everyone and by
firing this police officer that will be
justice because
we will be showing people that
we're not going to stand for it we're
not going to stand for it anymore
the um continual
the continual put downs the continual
terrorizing of communities
we deserve to live in our neighborhoods
we deserve to have lives
we deserve to matter finally let me ask
you mr lederman do you think the death
of george floyd the charges brought
against eric sheldon
will that lead to substantial change do
you think on the part
of the minneapolis police department in
the kind of cases you're talking about
um my personal opinion no um
i don't believe that um anything will
change um
mr floyd was not the first person to die
at the hands of minneapolis police
um and um he will not be the last
unfortunately
um the city has as we've heard the news
has settled his case with the family
uh which which i believe is appropriate
now but the question is is the
is the culture of abuse within the
minneapolis police department going to
stop
um and i haven't seen evidence of that
you know
given mr floyd's case and given prior
recent cases we have here
um i don't see any evidence of the
police department
changing substantially in a way that it
treats the public
coming up next showdown at amazon the
votes are being counted
on whether for the first time some of
its employees will join
a union you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime
trial network
the votes have been cast and now they're
being counted to decide whether for the
first time
workers at amazon might join a union
rhonda
it's a high-stakes battle for amazon the
second largest employer in the country
with nearly a million employees
they have fought off attempts to union
eyes before
but if this goes through it could be a
game changer for amazon brian
amazon is proud of the system it has
created to deliver
so much so quickly to so many americans
at amazon we're pretty good at getting
things done
it's the talk of the business community
amazon acquired its undisputed status as
the heavyweight champion of the retail
universe
thanks largely to its lightning fast
delivery times but some workers at its
so-called
fulfillment centers including this one
in alabama
say that the amazing distribution system
has come at a huge price for amazon
workers
who complain of harsh conditions and
unrelenting deadlines
efforts to unionize the workforce in
alabama are underway
with workers voting over the next few
weeks about whether to join
the retail wholesale and departments to
our union
we're joined now by two employees at
that amazon facility in alabama
jennifer and ervin both of who've been
connected with us uh through the union
thank you both for being here jennifer
you were telling me before we began that
you actually are in
physical pain working your 10 hour
shifts there
yes i am what's up what's it like
it's it's it's tough especially when
it's time to go to break and
you're thinking about should i take the
chance of walking out or should i just
stay where i am
and earl then do you feel the same sort
of thing are there physical pressures as
well as mental stress in the job there
i do i really do um
as far as climbing the stairs sometimes
um
the repetitive movement and things of
that nature uh
yeah so some jobs that you have to do
the repetitive movement but
you know to be like a robot so to speak
treated like a
number instead of a person um no one
wants to come to work and be treated
like a machine
and treat it like they're nothing
and ireland finally let me ask you this
if it's so bad why not just quit and
find another job
um easier said than done um
with the economy been how it is and with
the pandemic
you know jobs are smelling none um and i
really do feel like
um their amazon has potential to be a
better company than it is now uh
with the with the right
with the right leadership amazon says it
pays all of its workers
at least fifteen dollars an hour and
provides career opportunities
and that workers already get generous
benefits and health care
without a union and now the company has
started a national
media campaign with television ads
proclaiming what a fine company it is
i love that everybody is helpful here
work friends
turn into work family and how well its
workers are treated
to all of our amazon retail heroes we'll
continue to do everything we can
to keep you healthy safe and protected
we're joined now by stuart alpebaum
who's the president of the retail
wholesale
and department store union mr applebaum
thank you for being here
amazon says it pays more than the
minimum wage it pays more than fifteen
dollars an hour and provides all the
benefits that
your workers would get if they were in
your union
people say to us all the time
that it doesn't matter how much amazon
is paying them if they don't treat them
with respect
if they don't acknowledge their humanity
and that is why there is such an
enormous
turnover at amazon's facilities
it doesn't matter what they're being
paid
if amazon keeps on treating them the way
they do
and by that what do you mean well people
feel dehumanized and mistreated
people are people get their assignments
from a robot
they're disciplined uh by an app on
their phone
they're fired by a text message
they're forced to work at a pace that is
unsustainable
people get injured in amazon facilities
people are getting sick
and dying even before the pandemic
jeff bezos is one of his uh core
principles as he
uh took over and built amazon into the
behemoth that it is
has always opposed unions how hard are
they fighting you now
amazon is conducting one of the most
aggressive
anti-union campaigns we have ever
seen they're bombarding people with
um their anti-union propaganda that
even when you go to the bathroom
in the bathroom stalls they have
anti-union messages
posted at eye level if you're sitting on
the toilet
that's how expensive their campaign is
it's just this one facility in alabama
why
is amazon fighting so hard over that one
facility
and should you win there and you certify
the union what are the implications of
that
well i i think we have to look at the
implications
amazon understands that this is the
first
time ever that there has been an
election at one of their fulfillment
centers for the entire workforce
if the workers prevail
and the union is certified
that is going to start
an organizing effort at not just
amazon facilities all over the country
but it's going to
start it's going to ignite
an organizing movement at companies
all across this country i mean
what really uh bothers me is that our
message is a simple one
we are saying that amazon can do better
by its employees and jeff bezos
is privileged enough to be in a position
where he is able to do better
and we do not understand why he doesn't
all right stupid bomb thank you so much
for joining the president of the retail
wholesale and department store union
thank you for being here tonight
thank you for having me coming up next
this week's winners and losers in the
media
see if you agree with the decisions by
the editors of media and what they say
about
sharon osborne you're watching brian
ross investigates on the law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of meteorite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of meteorite
which like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media company
aiden your first winner leslie stahl of
60 minutes for her report this week on
what's going on
in wuhan we said
do you audit the lab and they said
annually did you audit it after the
outbreak yes was anything found no
do you test your staff yes no you're
just taking their word for it
well what else can we do there's a limit
to what you can do and we went right up
to that limit we asked them tough
questions
they weren't vetted in advance and the
answers they gave
we found to be believable
correct and convincing but weren't the
chinese engaged in a cover-up
they destroyed evidence they punished
scientists who were trying to give
evidence
on this very question of the origin
a tough interview in there by leslie
that's right so i think while some in
the media have done a poor job of
covering the theory that coronavirus
could have leaked out of a wuhan lab
which remains a theory uh i should note
leslie stahl of 60 minutes is
an exception there she was interviewing
one of the scientists that was part of a
team from the world health organization
that has taken china's opinion that
there's no way that this leaked out of a
wuhan lab
that's still a theory it's plausible and
she was asking tough questions
of a scientist who has sided with china
on that theory against that theory i
should say
so it's important that we have
journalists asking tough questions of
the people that are going to make the
determination of where
the virus came from and leslie stella
did a great job of that on 60 minutes
last night
and this week's loser sharon osborne
kicked off the cbs
program the talk as of last week
after this contentious exchange with
co-host cheryl underwood
i'm not racist neither appears racist
and i
hate the fact of even saying i'm not
racist
it's a it's a terrible evil
word to call anybody without
knowledge of that and don't try and cry
because if anyone should
be crying it should be me this is the
situation
you tell me where you have heard him say
educate me tell me when you have heard
him
say racist things educate me
tell me
so the dispute there aiden was over her
comments in defense of her friend
piers morgan who had criticized harry
and meghan
that's right so there was that moment uh
which came
just after uh prince harry and meghan
markle's
uh interview with oprah and she was
defending her old colleague
piers morgan many in media described
that as a meltdown on the show
in which she sort of confronted uh her
co-host
and in the aftermath of that reports
came out that she had used racial slurs
uh on against cast members on the show
um so it was obviously a very bad week
in headlines for sharon
osbourne and she exited the talk on cbs
on friday
now she is jobless and obviously it was
a very bad week for her
because of that and not a good week for
cbs i take it
no and you know the talk has always
struggled in the ratings
as of january it was down double digits
over the previous year
it draws about half the audience that
the view does on abc
so it's certainly not a very
particularly prominent
uh talk show um the exit of sharon
osborne has gotten it more pressed than
it has gotten in years
um and uh maybe new blood is something
that uh will be good for the show
well controversy never hurt the views or
perhaps it will help
the talk right yeah that's a good point
um but you know it might have been worth
keeping sharon osbourne on if they
wanted to hype up the controversy i know
that
uh some people thought that would help
good morning britain uh keeping piers
morgan on given that they had their
highest ratings in years
uh i think ever after uh his commentary
uh on the oprah interview
um but uh uh cbs the talk and uh and
good morning britain went in another
direction and decided to get rid of
those controversial hosts
all right well aidan mclaughlin thank
you so much for being with us this
evening and thanks to all of you for
watching
we'll be back next week and thanks to
our staff here at long crime for getting
us on the air and off
here
[Music]
so
you